JEREMY STERN: Good afternoon
and welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Jeremy Stern
with Google Fiber.
And our guest today
is Shaluinn Fullove.
Shal's been a
Googler for 13 years.
She started at Google
Search and moved
onto a number of other products,
and then became a Sloan fellow
at the Graduate School
of Business at Stanford,
returned after her
fellowship and worked
on apps and business
and Gmail, and then came
to join Google Fiber about
three years ago with me.
And when she's not
a full time Googler,
she is a full time mom
and a world class runner
and endurance athlete.
Let me share with you some
examples of her long list
of accomplishments in running.
Her personal record
running a marathon
is two hours, 41
minutes, and 57 seconds.
Think about that.
26.2 miles in under two
hours and 42 minutes.
That was her personal record set
in December at the California
International Marathon, and
it was a key race getting her
to this day.
And so we'll talk
more about that.
She also ran a
1,500 meter, a mile,
in under four minutes
and 35 seconds
in the US Track and
Field Pacific Association
Championships a few years ago.
She's in Los Angeles today for
the US Women's Olympic Track
Team Marathon Trials, on
the road to Rio in 2016.
This is a really big race
this Saturday for Shal,
and we're really lucky
to have her here.
Please join me in welcoming
Shal to Google Venice Beach.
And also her husband Ramsey and
daughter Elise and mom Marianne
are in the audience with us.
So welcome also to
Google Venice Beach.
Welcome.
It's been fun as a Google
Fiber teammate of yours
to follow your path here.
But I'm really excited
to have you here
and to share with the Google
audience and the YouTube
audience a little bit more about
you and your racing career.
So can you tell us a little
bit about-- first of all,
you're on the Google
Fiber project.
Tell us a little bit about
what Google Fiber is.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Google Fiber
is high speed internet and TV
for your home or small business.
And it's a gig, which is
a really big deal, right?
So it's a lot faster
than most of us
have unfortunately at our homes.
And I've been on the team
for about three years,
like you mentioned earlier.
JEREMY STERN: So over
13 years at Google.
What inspired you to
move from other projects
to come join the
Google Fiber team?
What was interesting
about the opportunity?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I've worked on
a lot of projects and products
since I've been here.
I think it's maybe
more than 12 products,
A lot of that is because
at the time, at Google,
we were launching a lot of
new products in early 2000.
So lucky to just be able
to move on to new products
that they were launching,
After almost 10
years at Google, if I
was going to
continue to be here,
I wanted to be
working on something
that was very audacious,
and a little bit scary.
And launching a new fiber
network seemed to kind of fit
that description, right?
So it's not an easy
problem to solve.
And we're chipping away at it.
So I'm really excited.
I've learned a ton about
the TV business and internet
and fiber.
So it's really kept me excited
to keep learning all this time.
JEREMY STERN: What do
you do on the Fiber team?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I sit on
the business development team.
And I work in the
strategy and operations.
I work closely with
yourself and Irv
and the content licensing
team to better understand
what we've signed up
for on the deal side,
and help product and
engineering understand
how to built a roadmap
around those obligations.
JEREMY STERN: So you're a full
time Googler, a full time mom.
How do you find time to be
a world-- how in the world
do you find time to become
a world class marathoner?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Well it's
not certainly not just me.
My husband, who's
here, who's also
a Googler, who's been at
Google as long as I have,
maybe longer, we're
definitely a team effort.
There's a ton of
people that help us
get everything done every day.
The schedule is every
day a game of Jenga
about who's going
to work out when,
who's going to take
Elise to school,
what's dinner going to be like.
We have help at home
too, which is great.
But we work together.
And it's a lot of working out
on the bookends of the day.
But I do get a chance to
work out at work a lot.
There's a great group of mostly
guys, the Mountain View Lunch
Run Group.
They're not watching
right now, probably
because they're on a run.
So sometimes I'm able
to get into running
during the workday.
JEREMY STERN: So the
race on Saturday,
February 13th, to qualify
for the US Olympic team,
it's Saturday in Los Angeles.
Tell us a little bit about the
Olympic qualifying process.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Sure.
So there's basically two
standards that get set.
The Olympic standard is set
by the International Olympic
Committee, and then
individual countries
have their own standard.
So initially, the Olympic
standard was 2:43,
and for the US, we
usually have a time that's
equal to the Olympic standard.
So if you've met
the US standard,
then you've automatically
met the Olympic standard,
so you already have that,
at least for the marathon.
It's a little bit
different in track.
So initially the
standard was 2:43,
and I just missed the standard.
I ran 2:43:33 in 2013,
so just by like a little
over a second in the mile I
missed the standard, which
was a little bit heartbreaking.
But I ran a good race, and
I was happy about that.
And so then in 2015,
I went and ran 2:41
and hit the 2:43 standard.
And then two days later, my
family and I were in Hawaii,
and the Olympic
committee announced
that they'd changed the
standard to two minutes slower,
so they changed
it to 2:45, which
is great news for
a lot of women,
because that meant they just
qualified for Olympic trials.
Sorry.
The Olympic committee
changed it to 2:45,
and then the US committee
a couple days later
agreed to change
it again to 2:45
to meet the Olympic standard.
So it's a little bit
unusual this year.
Initially, it was 2:43.
Now it's 2:45.
JEREMY STERN: Does
that mean there'll be
more women racing on Saturday?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
So I think something
like eight new qualifiers were
allowed to come into the race
after they moved the standard
back about two minutes, which
is great news all in all.
And then on Saturday,
the way it works
is there's a little less
than 200 people in the men's
and women's race, and
the top three finishers
will be the US Olympic
team that goes to Rio,
and the fourth place finisher
will be the alternate.
So it's a very
democratic process.
Yeah.
JEREMY STERN: Where is the
race taking place on Saturday?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: It
is down by LA Live.
It's roughly a five-loop course.
There's a two-mile
loop to begin with,
and then we do
four by six miles.
So it's a very
spectator-friendly course.
JEREMY STERN: So it's different.
The big LA Marathon
is Sunday, and that's
from Dodger Stadium to the sea.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Right.
JEREMY STERN: Not
a straight line,
but A to B. This is a completely
different course than that.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Yep.
It's definitely set up for
spectators to see a lot of us,
and it's not even
like a real loop.
It's almost like
an out and back.
So we'll be able to see a lot
of the spectators quite a bit,
which is nice for
such a long race.
JEREMY STERN: So have
you studied the course?
How do you prepare for
a particular race course
when you're getting your
game set, game mind going?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: They've had
a really good interactive maps
online.
They posted that awhile ago.
They didn't finalize the
course until not too long ago,
and they've had a
couple opportunities
for you to come down around
the course with some officials,
and I think I will probably try
to do a couple shakeout runs
on Thursday and Friday.
JEREMY STERN: Step back and
tell us about your journey
to this incredible day.
This isn't your first
Olympic trial, right?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Right.
I qualified in 2008.
JEREMY STERN: So tell us
about your prior efforts.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Yeah,
so I qualified in 2008,
and they were in Boston,
which was really special.
In 2005, I was diagnosed
with thyroid cancer
and overcame that.
It took about a year, so
I had to overtake that,
and it went really well.
I had great doctors,
but personally, I
felt like I wanted to prove that
I was like the same or better
than I was before
I got diagnosed
with this horrible disease.
And I decided I was going
to take some audacious goal
to prove that I had come
back stronger from that,
and qualifying for
the Olympic trials
marathon was what I chose.
JEREMY STERN: That's
pretty extraordinary.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: So
it was a hard road.
I had three attempts, and I
qualified just seven weeks
before the actual
Olympic trials in 2008
at the Napa Valley marathon,
so I had seven weeks
to turn around and come back.
And it was a great day, and
to have it be in Boston,
which is such a marathon
mecca-- Joanie Samuelson
was in the race that year.
I actually ended up running
a lot of the race just ahead
of her, but Boston went
crazy every time she came by.
So I felt like I had
support the whole time,
and every time we
came down Boylston,
because it was a
four-loop course,
so we came down
Boylston four times,
and the crowds were
just going crazy.
It was the day before
the Boston Marathon too,
so it was a really
great experience.
And then I stepped out of
2012, because I was still
on maternity leave.
I had a little baby,
and I decided, well,
I wanted to go for it again.
So eight years later I
decided to tackle it.
JEREMY STERN: What
inspired you to do it?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: To do 2016?
JEREMY STERN: 2016.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I think
you did it one time,
and you kind of want to say,
OK, did I just get lucky,
or was it just a fluke?
Do I still have it?
I think the time was
three minutes faster,
and I was going to be eight
years older, and I thought,
that seems like a
really hard goal.
I should just--
JEREMY STERN: An audacious goal.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Maybe I
should just go for it and see.
Sure, maybe I wouldn't get it,
but maybe I'd get pretty close.
And in 2013, I mean, I just
missed it by 33 seconds,
so I was like, I
have to try again.
So I was injured in 2014,
and I tore my hamstring
in early 2015.
So there's definitely been
some challenges along the way,
but I can be bullheaded at
times when it's helpful.
JEREMY STERN: So the race
in December in Sacramento--
is that where it was?
The California
International Marathon.
Your personal record,
extraordinary result--
tell us a little bit about that
race and the experience of what
it was like for you.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Sure.
I was really nervous that week.
The training had
gone really well,
but I was really nervous,
because the couple
years before when I ran it,
it was a really hard day.
It was 27 degrees, and I had
all of this horrible memory
of like-- I mean the
last mile and a half,
I was losing my vision.
It was just horrible.
So even though I
was fit this time,
you just think
about how much it's
going to hurt, that last 5K.
But my friends were
really supportive
and keeping my spirits up.
My coach is fantastic.
And basically, the gun went
off, and you're just kind of
out there.
In full honesty, I was kind
of grumpy the first 10 miles.
It was rainy, and it was dark,
and I was just like, oh, gosh.
It was crowded, and
all the water stops
are crowded, because we
hadn't strung out yet.
There were two pace groups,
and we were all kind
of just one at that time.
But I remember at
like 10K, I kind of
was in a group kind of settling
in [INAUDIBLE] in chunks.
So after the first 10
miles, like 11 to 15
is kind of the roll-y part, and
by that time, I'm like, well,
I'm out here.
So we're just going to be out
here and see what happens.
And 16 to 20, you get
a nice little downhill,
and I was feeling
good at that point.
I just remember my coach
saying, get to 20 under control,
because you can really open up
that last 10K if you feel good.
And after 20, I just kept
waiting for the wall.
I kept thinking about two
years before, where I just was
like dying and like
losing my vision.
But it never came, and
I couldn't believe it.
And actually my fastest
mile was mile 26.
I ran a 5:54 last mile, and I
just was gunning it for home.
And at mile 26, one of my best
training partner friends was
like, you've got to go now.
And I had my Garmin
on, and I knew
I was averaging like
6:10, 6:11, and I
was like, I think I got it.
But I needed to
run 6:13s or 6:12s,
so we were at like 6:10
or 6:11 the whole time,
and I had picked it up
the last three miles.
But she was screaming at
me like I didn't have it,
and I had to run 400 meters.
So I just started
running as hard
as I could, which was great
because I dipped right
under 2:42, which was great.
JEREMY STERN: That's
extraordinary.
So to get to that level of being
able to run at a 6:10, 6:11
pace for 26 miles, there's
a lot of endurance athletes
in this office
and across Google.
Tell us a little bit about
your training regimen.
What was it like and how did
you set your training regimen up
to hit that goal?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: My
coach is fantastic.
He's really a
marathon specialist.
His name's Michael
McKeeman, and I've
been training with him
for about three years.
And his training is very
different than any training
I did before.
So in college, I
was middle distance.
I loved the track.
I loved my 400s, maybe
some I'll repeat.
His training is
nothing like that.
His training is a lot of
tempo work, a lot of grindy,
sit in it race simulations.
So we do a ton of tempo.
All of my long runs have
marathon pace integrated
into it, so the hardest long
run I'll do is 22 miles,
and the last eight to
10 are at marathon pace.
So we do a lot of that work,
so when the race comes,
you feel very familiar
with what is going on.
And you're tapered,
so you feel great.
JEREMY STERN: So
do you start out--
I mean, how many
miles a week-- You're
six months out from the race.
How many miles a
week do you run?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I'm actually
relatively low mileage
for a marathoner.
I never go over 75 miles
a week, but all the work
we do during the week
is very high quality.
So I don't do a
lot of double days.
I do one double day a week,
and it's only three miles.
But I do a lot of tempo work.
But all the work
is a progression.
JEREMY STERN: I'm just
doing the math in my mind.
That's more than 10 miles a day.
I get tired thinking about that.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Well, a lot
of women that'll be racing
is on Saturday.
They run 100 to 140-mile weeks.
I mean, their full
time job is to run.
But I find that at
75 miles, things
start to get a little
frayed on the edges,
and I don't feel-- you
start to risk injury.
We do a lot of high
quality tempo work.
I told him after
this race, whatever
the next race we do, it has to
require a lot of 400 repeats,
because I don't want to do a
lot of tempo work for awhile.
But it's always a
progression, so I
don't start trying at 22
miles and every other week we
alternate.
So if it's not a
tempo long run, we'll
do it so that the last half is
alternating like an easy mile,
a race pace mile.
Those are his easy long runs.
JEREMY STERN: What
else besides running?
Do you add any other
fitness into your program?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I do a
little bit of yoga and Pilates.
I have recently learned that
my core needs a lot more work,
so I've been trying to integrate
a little bit more of that,
especially after
having a kid and just
being a little bit older.
You really need to focus
on that strong core.
JEREMY STERN: So
what about diet?
Do you have a program for
maintaining your metabolism
and your physiology for
maximum race performance?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: The one
thing about marathon training
is carbs.
You have to have a
lot of carbs, so--
JEREMY STERN: There are
good carbs and bad carbs.
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
Yeah, when you're
marathon training though,
it's just kind of all carbs.
You can eat all the
stuff that they usually
tell you not to eat, because
you're going to burn it up,
and your body uses that fuel.
So I don't spend a ton of
time like measuring food,
but I just try to
think generally
to make sure I'm
getting that protein.
I do think a lot about what I
eat immediately after the runs.
I found that if after a really
long hard workout or long run,
if I am able to get a
protein shake within 30
minutes of finishing, it goes a
long way to helping me recover.
JEREMY STERN: So what are
some of the sacrifices
along the way?
I mean, it's a marathon.
It's a long preparation course.
What are some of the
sacrifices that you have?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Probably a
better question for my family,
since they have to put up
with every weekend being
a long run, and my
husband bikes with me,
and he pulls the
buggy with a leash,
and they laid at the
three-mile mark with my water,
so their weekends are kind of
taken up with Mommy's running.
But I don't really
see the sacrifices.
I'm really focused on the goal.
I had my 15-year Stanford
reunion during the buildup,
so I had to miss a couple
of the things there.
But my roommates on the team,
they definitely understand.
They're so supportive.
I don't really think
about sacrifices.
I just think these
are the things
you have to do if you're
going to get your goal.
JEREMY STERN: One
of the things you're
mentioned in one of your
races like almost losing
your vision at the end, is
there's an extraordinary amount
of suffering and
endurance racing,
whether it's open water
swimming or running or biking
or triathlon.
How do you prepare
your mind for that?
I mean, a lot of
endurance athletes
that have written or
spoken about the subject
say there's a huge
part of the mind
game in terms of preparing.
So tell us about that, both
in training and racing.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Yep.
The mental game is
huge, definitely,
especially when you're
putting your body,
pushing your body to its max.
And I think one
of the reasons why
I was able to improve
so much in the marathon
over the last three years is
the training that I was doing,
not only physically where
we're obviously stimulating
the right system in those long
runs and those tempo efforts,
but you're really getting your
mind into that hurt zone, where
you're like, how am I
going to deal with this?
And there were definitely-- the
night before these long runs,
I'm emailing my coach.
I'm like, oh, I don't know.
And after three weeks
in a row of that,
you're kind of like, god,
I feel kind of burned out.
But I think mentally it's
training that mental muscle
to get prepared for that.
And I think sometimes you
break it into smaller chunks.
So like I did this year at CIM.
It was like the first 10 miles
and 11 to 15, and 16 to 20,
so it was little baby
steps to get there.
I think on Saturday,
having it be a loop course,
I'll be doing a lot
of that, so like,
can I get the two-mile loop?
Can I get the first
six-mile loop?
And I'm just taking
it one step at a time
and really not trying to consume
the whole 26 miles at once.
I think also having
teammates and training
partners is critical.
Some of these
workouts are almost
impossible to do by
yourself, but I've
been really fortunate to
loop in some Googlers,
some of the guys on
the MV lunch run,
and some old teammates
of mine from Stanford
have been able to
come out and help.
So it's not one silver bullet.
It's a lock in the mental game.
But I actually read the
book, "Flow," this buildup
of the CIM, which is really
helpful to think about how
to get in this flow state,
where you're effortlessly
losing yourself in the
moment and thinking about not
pushing too hard but trying
to find some flow, fluidity.
JEREMY STERN: So have you
ever felt that flow in a race?
I mean, because
clearly, there are
barriers, physical and
mental and weather.
Have you felt that flow, and
how do you keep yourself there?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Yeah, I think
sometimes it comes in spurts,
especially in the marathon.
I wasn't feeling any flow the
first 10K to 10 miles at CIM.
I was like, I'd rather be doing
almost anything else right now
than doing these first 10 miles.
But yeah, kind of
in the middle, you
start to kind of-- your
body starts to remember.
You realize you're here.
You're working with people.
You realize you're
getting closer.
I was holding back a
little bit that last 10K,
because I was bracing myself for
the wall to hit me pretty hard.
But then with the last 5K,
I realized it wasn't coming,
and I really just
needed to go for it,
so I started to embrace
it and really push.
But the truth is there are more
races where you don't feel flow
than when you do.
So when you feel it, you really
embrace it and try to enjoy it.
But more times than
not, you're grinding.
It's hard.
It's going to hurt.
JEREMY STERN: So I guess the
opposite of flow is suffer.
How do you-- you're
suffering at mile 15.
What inspires you, and how
do you-- because it's not
just your legs and arms moving.
It's your mind, again, taking
it back to the mental game.
How do you pull
yourself out of that?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: You've
got to stay positive.
In the marathon, it's
going to ebb and flow.
Mile 15 could feel horrible,
and then mile 16 and 17,
you could feel like
a million bucks.
So I think you just really
have to tell yourself
this is going to pass.
One of the things
we do in yoga is
you notice when you're
uncomfortable and acknowledge
that I don't feel great, and
I'm going to let go of it,
and I'm going to
keep moving forward.
You just have to keep
pressing and believing that.
You've train for this.
Other people are suffering.
We're working together.
Just keep getting to the
next mile and next mile.
But the reality is
the running, it hurts.
Racing hurts, and
it's not hurting,
you're probably not doing it
right, so you kind of just
have to accept that
it's going to hurt.
Admit to it.
You can't run away from it.
If you don't want to hurt, you
probably shouldn't try to race
or do running.
You should probably
do something else.
I coach a high school
team in Palo Alto,
and we talk a lot
about the pain cave.
JEREMY STERN: What is--
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
The pain cave, it's
like how the deeper you go
in the pain cave, that's
how you reintroduce yourself
to like new stimulus
and new pain, and throughout
the course of the season,
we talk about how we've already
gotten this far into the pain
cave, so now this time, we're
going to try to go further,
and by the time we get
to the championship,
we're going to commit ourselves
to going the deepest we've ever
been into that pain cave.
So it works for the high
school girls [INAUDIBLE].
They like it.
JEREMY STERN: What has been
the most challenging part
of maintaining this level
of performance for so long?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I
think I've been fortunate
that if you mapped
it in broad strokes,
it's been a really
nice progression.
So I came out of college being
a middle distance runner.
My coach, my marathon
coach initially, we
did a ton of track
work, so that felt
like a natural progression.
And now I'm with a new
coach who does a lot
of marathon-specific training.
I don't think right
out of college
I could have jumped
right into the training
that I'm doing now, and
I've been fortunate enough
to not have many
injuries along the way.
I've had a couple just
in the last two years,
but I've been able to
overcome those as well.
So it's been a
natural progression.
I love it.
I have a ton of
friends that do it.
Stanford actually
has upwards of nine
or 10 athletes that are going
to be competing on Saturday,
so it's been really great just
after all this time to still
have that camaraderie
from the Stanford team.
JEREMY STERN: Do
you have any words
of wisdom for the endurance
athletes here in this audience
and in our TV audience
on how to keep going,
how to keep inspired?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
I don't know if I
have a lot of words of wisdom
or inspiration to share.
But I think for me, being
surrounded by teammates
and training partners is
like the number one thing.
I run for an all women's team.
They're actually an apparel
brand named Oiselle.
We have the most women at
the trials on Saturday.
We have 18 women who
qualify, and being
a part of that
community has pushed me
and helped me reignite
a fire for this sport
that I've been doing since
I was-- I've been competing
since I was five years old.
But it's been so amazing to be
surrounded by so many women who
are-- we have at least woman
who has a really good chance
to make the team.
She made the team
in 2012-- to women
who just run on the weekend, and
we all on social or at meetups
support each other equally,
which is fantastic.
For me personally, having
a coach is critical.
There is no way I could
write a training plan
and be a mom and work, so
having a coach that I can really
trust who's invested in me
and who I can just fully trust
the process with is important.
JEREMY STERN: What
are qualities that you
look for in your coach?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: It's funny.
So I was friends with friend
with-- Michael McKeeman
is my coach.
I was friends with him from
another training partner
of mine, and I literally was
wishing him happy birthday
on Facebook on his
wall, and then realized
that he was also coaching.
And I just said,
will you coach me?
And he was like, sure.
But he has amazing experience.
He actually was Deena
Kastor's training partner
for many years up in Mammoth.
She's an American record holder,
so we spent a ton of time
learning from some of the best
marathon coaches in the US.
So someone who just has
a ton of experience,
someone who understands me
as a whole person, not just
an athlete.
I think sometimes
it's easy for coaches
to just think about
you as an athlete,
but he respects that
I work full time,
that I have parental duties,
but he doesn't let me back down
from trying to go for these
really big audacious goals.
So he doesn't pull back my
workouts just because I work
and be a mom, which is great.
JEREMY STERN: What's
your favorite workout?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
I love porters,
which I don't have
to do very much when
I'm doing marathon training.
But the best workout
leading into the marathon,
we build up to a
12-mile tempo run, where
the first 400 of every
mile is at about 10K pace,
and the last 1,200
is at marathon pace.
And what's awesome about
that is it breaks it up,
so you kind of start
to think about, oh,
I'm just doing 400s with
a 1,200-meter recovery,
but you end up running 12 miles.
I think I did this two
weeks before the race,
and I did 12 miles at
6:05 pace in practice,
which we did it at Google
with Matt Cook, who's
a fellow Googler.
And when you nail that
workout, you feel really good.
I emailed my coaches.
I can't believe I
just did that workout.
You know you're ready to race.
JEREMY STERN: Before
I open the floor up
for questions from
the audience, let
me ask you some fun questions.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: OK.
JEREMY STERN: So we talked
a little bit about diet.
Sounds kind of flexible,
but did you ever
cheat on your diet in the
lead-up to this big race?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I think around
Thanksgiving and my birthday,
I think we went up
to Napa to celebrate,
and I think maybe I
had a little more wine
than I normally would.
You've got to stay
hydrated, so I
try not to drink too much
wine while I'm building up.
But I'm a big believer
in treating yourself,
so after big workouts--
like every weekend,
I go to the same restaurant
and get a big stack of pancakes
and butter and syrup
and all that stuff.
But yeah, I don't
cheat too much.
JEREMY STERN: So what's
your favorite food
after finishing the race?
Where are you going
to go after this race?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: That's
a popular question.
So one of my favorite
restaurants in LA
is Rustic Canyon,
and they have--
or they at least used
to have a great burger.
It's not on the menu.
If you ask for it, they
have it, and it's delicious.
And I booked that reservation
like the day after I qualified,
so we're going to Rustic
Canyon on Saturday night.
JEREMY STERN: Tell us about
your funniest race or training
experience, if there can
be a funny race or training
experience in a marathon.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I
don't know it's funny,
but in 2008-- I mentioned this
a little bit earlier-- in Boston
at the trials, I was
running basically
just a couple meters ahead of
Joanie Samuelson the whole way.
And I thought, oh, maybe-- I
don't know what I was thinking.
Of course, she's going to
just be as strong as nails
and be there the whole time.
But she just kept being
there, and it came down
to like the last 400 meters,
and we're on Boylston,
and the crowd is going crazy.
There's a giant screen on
the road, and I look up,
and I can see her
like behind me,
and she is just crushing
like the last 200 meters.
I had to run a 38-second
last 200 meters just to not
get caught by Joanie, who I
think broke the 50-year-old age
group record that day.
So I remember just
running for my life trying
to not-- in my
mind, I'm like, I'm
going to be a gold
medalist in the marathon.
But obviously,
that was not real.
That really did happen.
I have awesome photos from the
Jumbotron on Boylston of that.
JEREMY STERN:
That's pretty cool.
So let me turn it
over to the audience.
Anybody have any
questions for Shal?
Please join us at
the microphone.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] do
a race, what do you do?
What's your schedule
like, and long
does it take to
recover and everything?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I
usually take about a month
where I'm doing
just almost nothing
of very unstructured work.
I usually like to go to
Hawaii right after marathons.
I don't like to run in Hawaii,
so I like to go like the week
afterwards, and we
just kind of veg out.
So we actually did that
after CIM this year.
We went for a week and
just hung out on the beach.
And then the next three weeks
is just very unstructured,
staying loose.
And then it's a very
gradual buildup again.
We don't hit it very hard
probably for another few weeks.
This time was a little bit
different and for '08 too,
because I had seven weeks
between '08 and the trials,
and this time I had 10.
So we didn't have as much
downtime as we wanted to.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
some of the Olympics trials
seemed to take place
the day before one
of the large marathons, so is
there some reason why they've
been avoiding the
crowds that just
don't do the trials
on the regular course?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I
think that it's just
more spectator-friendly
to have the loops.
There may be a rule, some kind
of international standard rule
that they do it that
way for some reason.
But I think having it the day
before a big race like Boston
or LA, it helps bring a lot of
the fanbase out. [INAUDIBLE]
get huge support.
I suppose they could, but
those races are quite large.
We're talking like
30,000 to 50,000 people,
and there's only going to
be 200 people in this race.
So it's nice that
they kind of create it
as a special kind of
celebration for people
going for the Olympic team.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have a story
of how your training
or how running the
marathons has helped
you develop professionally?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Sure.
Let me think about
that for a second.
I think a lot of the
qualities that you
develop as an
athlete, especially
being an athlete
your whole life,
are things that transfer well
into other parts of your life.
So even before I was
a working professional
being a student athlete,
your dedication, your ability
to stay focused on the goal,
even when things aren't going
perfectly, or you're
in that midspot where
it's kind of grindy, and
it's not always the most fun.
I think also being an
athlete, every time you race,
there's an opportunity
to win, but there's also
an opportunity to lose.
And how do you deal with
failure and learn from that
and get up again and go?
And so I think with Google,
we push really hard.
We want to fail
fast, learn, iterate,
and I think being an
athlete, that transfers over.
That's very relatable to me.
It wasn't something that was
new to me when I came to Google.
I'd been doing that since
I was five years old.
So I think those
elements of being
an athlete transfer really well
into your professional life.
JEREMY STERN: Please.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
More than one question.
Do you have a favorite
marathon course?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I think
I've run six marathons.
I haven't run that many.
I guess I've run Cal
International the most,
and it's been the
most friendly to me,
so I think that's probably
my favorite right now.
It's close to my
house, and it's fast,
and they do a great
job organizing it.
But I haven't run that
many, so I run it the most,
so I guess I would go
with Cal International.
But anyway, if you're thinking
about doing a marathon,
it's a fantastic marathon.
They do a great job.
It's small, well-organized,
and it's fast.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
advice for people who have never
done any exercise in
their life but started
doing some running in their
30s or 40s for the first time?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
Yeah, absolutely.
I would recommend getting
together with a group.
It doesn't have to be someone
who has a dedicated coach
or anything, but there are so
many good running communities
to just motivate you
and help you and help
you to learn so that you can
kind of go at your own pace
and have fun with it.
I think if it's not fun,
you won't stick with it.
And the pain part isn't
so much fun all the time,
but it is often
the most rewarding,
so you'll have a team around
you to help you get through that
and push.
So I would recommend trying to
find a local community group
or even just weekly
runs at shoe stores
often are very helpful
ways to get started.
Hi, Herb.
AUDIENCE: Did you race
any other distances
competitively,
and then what made
you transition to start doing
the marathon piece side of it?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
Yeah, I started
running middle distance.
JEREMY STERN: What
is middle distance?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
A middle distance
is-- so when I was in college,
it was the 1,500 and 3K.
That was before they had
the 3K steeple for women.
So now they have a 3K steeple,
and then there's the 1,500,
and the 5K is typically
middle distance.
I think I always really
wanted to be a miler.
A mile is such a great distance.
But I think when I
ran my first marathon,
I just wanted to
tackle something
that I hadn't done before,
so there was no precedent,
no comparison point.
The marathon seemed big.
If you can do that,
you feel like even
if it wasn't like an awesome
time, you ran a full marathon,
so that's great.
I think if you watch a
lot of the people who
are racing on
Saturday, eventually,
everyone arrives
at the marathon.
Eventually, they just keep
moving up in distance.
If you're a 400-meter
runner in high school,
you're going to run the
eight and 15 in college,
and after college, you're
going to run the five and 10.
So in some ways, you kind of
always end up in the marathon,
but for me, it was just more
of like, can I really do this?
My training for
the first marathon
was definitely more
middle distance training.
I thought three by a mile
was like the big workout.
So I survived that marathon,
but I learned that that really
wasn't marathon raining.
JEREMY STERN: When you were--
what's your fastest mile time
ever when you were doing--
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I think I run
the equivalent of like 4:52,
which isn't-- for a miler
is not amazing, but for me,
it was the best I could do.
Maybe that was also a
reason why I decided
to go back to the marathon.
I realized the mile really
wasn't working out for me.
It really wasn't.
It didn't have that turnover.
As much as I loved the
work training for it,
it really wasn't working out.
JEREMY STERN: So I
remember us talking
about this in terms of
motivation, getting ready,
and you said to me
once that there's
nothing like putting
a race on a calendar
to get you motivated to train.
So when you decided
to go for it in 2016,
what were the key dates
for your thinking?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: So I had
an injury in April and May.
I actually had a
torn hamstring, which
is one of the worst runner
injuries you could probably
ask for.
So we had that as
a starting point.
I actually had PRP
to help that repair,
and so we knew
that that was going
to be eight to 12 weeks until
I could start training again,
and then we needed X
amount of time for buildup,
so we're looking
at a fall marathon.
So there were maybe three
marathons that we looked at.
We thought about Chicago,
which was kind of early, maybe
Philadelphia, which is
really close to CIM,
and we just thought,
give us a little bit
of extra time in case we missed
a couple weeks of training.
And CIM is so close to my
house, so it was actually
pretty straightforward
to try to figure out,
because we had
some pretty locked
in time frames
based on the injury
that we had to work with.
AUDIENCE: Question.
Thanks for the celebration
in Hawaii and Rustic Canyon.
But what are some of
the rituals that you
go through the morning of?
It's game day or
right in the moments
before you start, what
are some of the things
that you need to do to
get you in that mindset?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
This time around,
I spent a lot of
time journaling.
I record a lot of my
training on Strava online,
which is great for visual.
But I've been spending a lot
of time in my Believe journal,
where I write down a lot
of the qualitative aspects
and write letters to myself.
And I was really
nervous going into CIM,
because I have a
couple page letter,
where I was just like
talking to myself,
telling myself to believe.
I spent a lot of time going
back and looking at the workouts
that I've done to just remember
all the work that you've done
and that you've actually
prepared for this moment
and you're ready.
Other than that, there's
a lot of carbo loading,
especially as you get
closer to three days out,
which is fun, so I
try to like constantly
be eating carbs to the point
where you get to race day,
and you're like, I don't
want any more carbs.
I don't want anything that
looks like a carb or tastes
chewy or anything.
But the journaling and the
reflection and that piece
is a really important part.
That's just the mental game.
There's nothing else
to do physically.
You can only do
harm at that point.
JEREMY STERN: So on race
day, Saturday, you wake up.
What time is the
race by the way?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: The women's
race I think is at 10:22.
It's a little bit later
than you would normally
have for a marathon,
and you guys
are having some hot
weather right now.
I think the men go at 10:00
and the women go at 10:22,
so at least I get to
sleep in and like wake up
at a decent hour and have some
breakfast and digestion and all
that.
JEREMY STERN: Please.
Any other questions for Shal?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Since your mom is
here, I want to know
that you run really fast.
I cannot even think about
running one mile at four
minutes.
I want to know, where do you
think this is coming from?
Genes or this is coming from--
your mom run marathons too?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I come
from a very athletic family,
but almost everyone in my
family were basketball players.
Both my parents played
basketball in college.
My brother was a very successful
basketball player at UCSD.
I think my mom started to run
track in college a little bit.
She ran a bunch after
when I was growing up,
which was hugely influential.
I actually thought
a long jump pit
was a sandbox for the kids
whose parents were running
on the track. [INAUDIBLE],
and I went to the track,
and I would just go sit in
the long jump pit and play.
So certainly, I think
genetics for sure, definitely.
AUDIENCE: So besides
marathons, do
you run other professional
sports like, as you said,
middle distance, 5K, 10K?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
The last couple years
I've been focused
on the marathon,
but I'm looking
forward to running
some personal bests and
some shorter distances
like the 5K and the 10K.
I've dabbled in
track a little bit,
but all the track races
right now are college,
and I just feel like an old lady
out there with those college
athletes.
So I don't know.
I'm going to probably
stick to the roads.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Oh, before?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
So I'm saying when you were
in college, high school,
did you run other professional
sports like [INAUDIBLE]?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I did grow
up playing different sports.
I dabbled in soccer
a little bit.
That didn't last super long.
I played basketball in high
school for a couple of years.
I swam my age group when
I was really little,
kind of before high school.
But I've done running
most consistently.
I put on my first uniform when
I was five or six years old.
JEREMY STERN: Suzanna.
AUDIENCE: I have a
longstanding prejudice.
Whenever I hear a marathoner,
I think that person is crazy.
So far, you have gone quite
a ways to dispel that notion,
but I'm still a
little bit suspicious.
Can you please explain it to me?
How are you not crazy/
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I never
said I wasn't crazy.
I actually just had this
conversation with somebody
in the last couple weeks.
My crazy comes out the
closer we get to the face.
You can talk to my husband
maybe after the talk.
See how crazy I get.
It took me about a zillion
hours to pack last night,
to think about all the
things we had to do.
So yeah, I mean
there definitely is
a bandwidth of crazy probably
amongst all of us runners.
But I don't know.
There's a little crazy.
There's a little crazy to go
out there and try to do this,
and to put yourself
through so much pain.
But I've been in this
sport a really long time.
I'm very fortunate
for that, and I
think you learn to
enjoy the ups and downs,
and you really do
focus on the long.
I want to be running
well beyond Saturday.
when I'm much older.
I want to set a good example
for the athletes that I coach.
So you think about all those
things, and my daughter,
she's going to be out there.
I want to set a good
example for that.
So that helps make sure that
you kind of check yourself
on how you're
approaching things,
and I also have a
great group around me--
coaches and doctors
and teammates, who
I can use as a sounding board.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
you said that when
you ran your first
marathon that it maybe
didn't go quite as
well as you had hoped,
and at least my
experience when you
start getting into
different sports
or into a different
aspect of that sport
is you meet people
who are much better.
And so how did you go
from like, oh, I did this,
and I didn't quite
do as well as I
wanted to really being
at the elite level
that you're at right now?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I've been
lucky to-- some of my teammates
now, we've been teammates
since we were-- gosh,
almost 20 years.
And I've been lucky to be
[INAUDIBLE] a long time.
So I think any time
you try a new distance,
you're going to open yourself
up to a lot of learning.
We'll call it learning.
But I think you learn
from that, and then
you meet people like you
said, and you talk to them,
and you try to learn about that
new distance or that new part
of the sport that you're
trying to get after.
But I've been really
lucky to be in the sport
with some of the best
for a very long time.
Like my time at
Stanford, I'm just
so honored to be included
in that list of alumni.
AUDIENCE: You've spent
a lot of time preparing
for the marathon, and this
time around, the weather
isn't the most
optimal, shall we say,
for running a marathon,
or some time or another,
maybe you're not feeling well.
How do you adjust
your expectations
after months of training
for an exceptional goal,
and then maybe everything
isn't as conducive as you
might want it to be otherwise?
SHALUINN FULLOVE:
The weather is always
a factor in the marathon,
and it's always something
we have zero control on.
So we try not to think
too much about it,
and then we just try to deal
with the circumstances that
were given.
This time around
for Saturday for me,
it's been a bit of an
unconventional buildup,
because we've had
a short buildup.
It's only been 10 weeks
since my last marathon.
I've had a small injury
that's come up the last three
weeks that we've had to really
change the training around
to accommodate.
And then we have
this big wrinkle
that it's going to be
in the 80s on Saturday.
So we've done a lot
of recalibrating,
and at some point, you
can have a game plan.
You can have your A, B,
and C goals, but in the day
you get out there, you
have to trust yourself.
That was the advice
my coach gave me.
We were just talking
yesterday about why we
do a lot of unstructured runs.
You have to know how your
body feels and trusts,
and you know what
you can do, and just
to run within yourself.
AUDIENCE: How have you felt
in all this preparation,
and how far has
it taken you away
from your normal routine
with your family?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: There 's
definitely been moments.
I've been really lucky to be
able to do a lot of racing
close to home and to have such
great, great, great training
grounds really
close to my house,
and some of the best
doctors and physios
are in our neighborhood,
so that's been awesome.
Google actually has
been really supportive,
so the last couple
summers, we've
actually been able to
go to the Boulder office
for an extended stay and work
a little bit from the Boulder
office and train at altitude.
So I've been really fortunate
to be able to take my family.
Elise is not quite
school age yet,
so we're able to spend a lot
of time not having to work
around a school schedule.
So that's been fantastic.
I did have this injury come up
a little bit in the last three
weeks, so I've had to do
a little bit more travel
to go see some
specialists about that.
And luckily, they've just
been extremely supportive,
and we just try to make it
as efficient as possible
to go down there and do
the work and come back.
Work's been extremely
accommodating as well.
JEREMY STERN: One
of the things you
learn both in work and athletics
is envisioning an outcome.
What do you envision on
Saturday at the finish line?
Are you thinking about it?
SHALUINN FULLOVE: I
am thinking about it.
I feel a little bit like
I need to crystallize
that over the next 72 hours
definitely, maybe 48 hours.
It's been an
unconventional buildup.
This injury's been a
little bit of a wrinkle.
The heat's going to be a factor.
I think ultimately,
where I'll land
is I'm going to try
not to overthink it.
I'm going to get out there
and run really smart,
and not forget to
enjoy it, because this
is quite a moment that won't
come again until-- maybe never
again, but it's
not going to come
before four years from now.
So I need to spend
some time in my journal
and around my teammates, who
all get into town tomorrow,
and that'll probably help
me start to think about it
and feel good about it.
JEREMY STERN: Well, Shal, on
behalf of everyone at Google,
we wish you the best
of luck in this race.
It's an extraordinary
opportunity on the road to Rio,
and thank you so much for
joining us on Talks at Google,
and wishing you
the best of luck.
So thank you so much.
SHALUINN FULLOVE: Thank you.
JEREMY STERN: Very exciting.
[APPLAUSE]